Speaker 1: . They are continuing to attack Dr.
Anthony Fauci. They want to see him in prison.
Many of them do. For what crime? We don't really
know. And the latest is that Donald Trump's former
economic adviser, Peter Navarro, says that he will
force Fauci to admit that he created COVID. Now,
how that if it's the China virus,
as they say, and China created it,
how is it that Fauci created it? It doesn't really
make sense. We're going to look at this clip
and consider how extreme, how dangerous,
how disturbing it is that they want to go
after medical doctors who just give us their best
advice at the time. These are sick people. Here's
Peter Navarro on Newsmax. Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Here's your future, Tony.
Republicans are going to sweep and take the
House back from Nancy Pelosi. And as soon as
that happens, you're going to sit your ass down in
a chair in Congress and you're going to confess to
creating the virus that's killed almost a million
Americans. Now, all on your watch, sir. And then
we're going to figure out.
Speaker 1: He's talking
about Fauci again, just as a reminder.
Speaker 3: Of the special deals you had with all
those grant money things. And we're going to fit
you for an orange jumpsuit, Tony. You can count
on that. So so don't be smug on CNN, dude. Okay.
Speaker 1: So this is all a reaction to a comment
that Dr. Fauci recently made. Dr. Fauci was asked,
you know, he served under Donald Trump. He was
made chief medical adviser under Joe Biden.
And he was asked if Trump comes back in 2024,
would you serve under Trump? And Fauci essentially
said no. Now, I actually think that it's sort of
a non question. Anthony Fauci is now what is
is he 81? He's 81 years old. If and when Trump
comes back, he would be close to 85 years old. I
anticipate that Dr. Fauci is going to be retiring
in the next few years. So at the end of the day,
I don't really believe it's even a choice Dr.
Fauci would be making. Will I or won't stay under
Donald Trump? I could be wrong, but it is to some
degree a political statement. I mean, Dr. Fauci is
saying it was so crazy trying to deal with COVID
under Trump that if Trump comes back, I'm out,
that's fine. Why is the right obsessed with going
after medical doctors? Well, one of the answers
is their political ideology that they espouse
since the start of the pandemic. Be very skeptical
of vaccines, be skeptical of masks. Be skeptical
of whether staying away from people physically
even really prevents the spread of the virus,
being skeptical about the fact that this is much
more deadly than the flu. All of these different
things, all of the political positions, all of the
medical positions that they staked out were not
really medical positions. They weren't really
science based positions. They were political
positions made to perpetuate their own ideology of
so-called freedom and all these different things,
and to make Donald Trump's failed response
look less bad or to even look good,
if you can imagine it. And so when that's
the political position that you stake out,
you have to make those who have a different view.
Your enemies and the medical science community had
a different view. The medical science community
had views that differed about guidelines, safety
guidelines, vaccines, masking all these different
things. And so you have to make them your enemies.
And that is a it's a feature rather than a bug
of modern reactionary politics. It's not just,
you know, we kind of have like a different
perspective about the correct level of taxes
or whatever the case may be, which is like, okay,
well, we can disagree, but it's not as I mean,
I would argue it's pretty clear what is better
economically when it comes to taxes, but there
is more of like an ideology associated with it
and the spirit of what the government should
be doing in terms of taxation. Okay. With a lot of
these COVID related things, it's just the science.
That's all it is. And when you are basing your
politics on reactionary fear mongering and arguing
that those with a different view are evil, and
on and on and on, when that's your perspective,
you have to attack everybody and make everybody
your enemy. And so doctors become your enemy.
And that's exactly what we're seeing. Now, I
want to go back to the obvious hypocrisy. Trump
called it the China virus. China did it. China
created it. But at the same time, they want to
blame Dr. Fauci. It seems like hypocrisy. But
remember, hypocrisy has no bottom or no top,
I guess, depending on your perspective with the
modern right wing. So what will they come up
with? I am sure that they will say, well, no foul.
She had and funded China creating it. That's how
they will square the two. Peter Navarro really
makes Mypillow Mike Lindell seem like kind of a
reasonable guy. He makes him seem almost sane.
And the really scary part is that the rhetoric
is becoming more overtly violent even now, talking
about imprisoning or going after medical doctors,
and they're doing it all out in the open.
It's becoming normal. It's extraordinarily
unsettling how comfortable the modern American
right is with threats of violence, threats of
suspending due process, and just just jail people.
Just put them in jail. Very, very scary stuff